at amazon music
one of our goals is to essentially
when the user asks alexa to say hey play
some music we want to be able to to play
the right content right away all the
time however
we're sometimes we're missing some
information to do that so
we were wondering like what if we start
asking some question to the user can we
prove the overall
recommendation quality
so we launched the first conversational
experience about two years ago
and
essentially users can say alexa help me
find music and then alexa starts asking
some questions like the
the
about the mood of the user for example
um then user can specify some constraint
like oh i would like like
90s rock
then alexa can decide to
choose a specific entity and play an
audio sample to the user
and it sounds like this
no problem try this
[Music]
nirvana
[Music]
did you like it
so then like if you're not into grunge
music like in the morning the you can
just say you don't want that and then
provide other constraints and alexa can
choose to ask more questions
and and essentially the conversation
ends when
the the user accepts the content that we
recommended like by starting a playlist
or the user abandons
behind this experience a key question is
what questions should we ask in what
order
so there's a wide range of questions we
can we can we can ask like from very
broad questions on the left to more
specific questions on the right
and those questions are very different
properties for example the ones on the
left they
tend to impose a fairly high cognitive
load on the user because the user has to
figure out something on the spot
the questions on the right they impose a
much lower cognitive load because the
user can just say yes or no for example
on the other hand the question on the
right they require
very good personalization um to get it
right
so we can say it's far from trivial to
to decide on what question to ask so we
decided to model this as a reinforcement
learning slash bandit problem
and we want to learn a dialogue policy
that tells us what alex i should say
next to maximize some measure of test
success
and more specifically instead of
building some kind of user simulator we
want to learn from live log data
um
and so to summarize we want to learn a
target policy from data collected using
a logging policy
and this is part of a larger offline
policy optimization framework
in which um we start by collecting some
randomized uh conversational data with
live users
then we make sure we log the state the
action the action probability and the
reward at every step of the conversation
and once you have collected data we can
use that to do offline policy
optimization and evaluation
counterfactually this we can try all
sorts of parameters exploration
techniques and by counter factory i mean
we want to estimate the reward of the
policy that we just trained even though
we only collected data
using a logging policy
so once we that allows us to pick a good
candidate we can deploy other customers
and do an a b tests and we can confirm
whether the the new policy uh beats the
the old one and if you want to improve
the the experience we can
let's add a prompt we can go back to
collecting more randomized data and
start again
so i'll focus a little bit on the the
counterfactual evaluation um we use
important sampling also called inverse
propensity propensity scoring
and essentially the idea is that we have
a logged reward from the logging policy
and we can just reweight them using the
probability of a target reaction
according to the target policy divided
by the
pro the action probability according to
the logging policy and with this
rewaiting we get a unbiased estimator uh
which you've probably heard of but um
yeah it's unbiased but it's a fairly
high variance this is all sort of strict
to reduce that variance and in our work
we started using the the sequential
version of this estimator
so what should we optimize for so in our
experience it would make sense to
optimize for task success that is did
the user end up playing something very
recommended at the end of a conversation
however for our first um
our first models we decided to focus on
something that's potentially less noisy
and we call that
prompt usefulness
and so it's a slight tweak on test
success for a prompt to be successful
um not only
does the conversation need to be
successful but also the prompt
needs to yield to an answer from the
user that that's actually useful into
finding the entity that gets played at
the end so for example if we suggest
80's music and the user says yes and you
play 80s music at the end then we get a
usefulness of one if have you played
like 70s music at the end the usefulness
of that prompt would have been zero
so in order to
to
learn what to ask next we need to define
a feature representation for the state
or the context
and we use features characterizing the
information that the user provided
within the conversation the length of
the conversation the the
subscription tier of the user and many
more features we'll see the feature
representation for every action by
action i mean an actual prompt a
candidate prompt and we use
we represent the meaning representation
of the prompt for example the type of
slots being represented like genre era
artists we also have features for the
type of of question being asked whether
it's open-ended or our suggestion or
something else
and also
we
also
have a embedding based affinity feature
that tells us the affinity between the
the user and the entity being suggested
i'll get back to that one later
so once we have our state representation
and our prompt representation the
simplest kind of policies we can we can
build our
reward regressors or value-based
policies where you simply concatenate
those two features and you're trying to
learn a function that predicts the
reward for every
state and prompt pair
and once you've done that you can use
any kind of exploration scheme
or you can use a greedy action selection
by picking the action with the largest
reward and what's nice about the offline
policy
evaluation framework that you can try
out all those types of model and
exploration schemes and see which one uh
you can estimate the performance of each
one of those
so we compared a few a few um algo items
so we we
we we compare offline linear models with
a template and sampling for exploration
we also evaluate uh neural bandits um we
also tried
an extra boost regression tree
with boltzmann exploration
and recently we just started looking at
a
policy based method by looking at
offline policy gradient
so
in our first offline experiment we only
assess
can we can we do better than our
rule-based system that was in production
for like for like a year or so it was a
fairly decent rule-based system
which has seen a lot of traffic so we
collected some data and um
we did a regular like
cross-validation and we were able to
measure the predicted reward for all
those models and we found that xj boosts
somehow surprisingly perform uh
better than our rules by 12 relative in
terms of from usefulness so that was
pretty encouraging so we picked that
model to deploy to customers
so then we want to check whether this
actually makes a real impact uh with
live users so we did a b test
just comparing the rules with the
xjboost policy
what we found is that um we got an 18
lift in question and prompt usefulness
which can be expected because that's the
metric we optimize against
we also found an 8 percent left in tax
success by test success i mean the
number of conversations that end with
playback
interestingly we also noticed that for
conversations that led to playback those
compensation ended up being like 20
shorter so that was a great finding for
us it means the users get what they want
more often also quicker
so in that first experiment we
we we only had one candidate prompt that
presented a specific entity so the model
had to pick between decide whether like
what question to pick or whether to
recommend something
uh in the second experiment we want to
evaluate whether we could extend the
sets of of candidate entities
suggestions that we want to learn not
just when to recommend but also what to
recommend using a single model so
what we did is extending the set of
candidates by adding multiple entities
based on the search results of our
search engine
and we in order to be able to
discriminate between those entities we
um we added a single um
embedding affinity feature between the
user and the entity being suggested
and
again we did the same offline policy
optimization and evaluation work to pick
a model
with hyperparameter tuning we deployed
that to customers and even a b test to
compare it to the previous model
and what we found is that with a single
feature we get a four percent lift in in
terms of the conversation that lead to
playback
and you also
found another 13
reduction in conversation length for
successful conversations so that was
also a great result because it's only by
adding a single a single action feature
to a model
all right so in terms of future work um
so we don't want to investigate moving
away from fully observable states to
partially observable states the idea is
that we want the model to learn um
to to to to learn from the dialogue
history uh what to what to say next
and you also want to look at more fine
grain variation like looking at natural
language generation to control things
like stylistic variation and also for
example
how to whether we can recommend multiple
items in a single entrance
and you also recently launched our first
multimodal experience
um
for our conversation so we want to an
interesting area of work is to
to train a policy that you predict
voice action but also predict visual
actions
okay so um beyond um conversational ai
we'll have lots of other interesting
projects at amazon music like focusing
just straight on on music recommendation
like when user says alexa play music
like what do we what do we serve
um we also have a
a great team focusing on language
understanding to parse complex alexa
entrances like those one and finally we
also have a search team that focuses on
finding the right entity given a complex
set of user constraints
so if you're interested in any of those
projects feel free to email me we're
looking for machine learning scientists
software engineers and you're
looking in san francisco it's a very
cool office so please write me an email
if you're interested and
thank you for listening and open to
answering questions
[Applause]
so we actually have a question online
from andrea barata
could the simulator be built to simulate
conversations to try and offline or
enforce learning policies will save
safer explorations that consider
long-term rewards for instance a
simulator might be useful to study
approaches like monte carlo research
like what research
monte carlo research i see
yeah i mean we could definitely yeah we
even have some data from users we could
use to train a trainer simulator um it's
just that we
this was kind of like a last resort i
know there's a lot of other efforts that
involve simulation that that makes that
makes it much easier to
to investigate more higher capacity
models um because obviously data is a
limitation
however
to us it's not really clear that
that you can learn much more than what
you put in that simulator so
so we're trying to see how much we can
go without any simulation
um
and that's kind of our so that's kind of
right now that's that's that's what we
want to focus on um and we'll
the other challenge is that a simulator
is just very hard to build a reusable
simulate simulator and you could argue
it's probably harder to build a good
simulator than building a good dialogue
policy in the first place
so
so yeah i think it's possible but it's
not really something we're focusing on
now okay thank you very much um can you
also comment please on kind of like any
heroistics on how how you generated the
embeddings kind of like what were the
approaches that you used for them oh i
see um yes so
this work kind of assumes that there's a
latent representation available to it to
you so we did not really
um i know
there's some other work that tries to
update create the embeddings based on
the result of a conversation but we are
assuming the embeddings are there for
users and items so um yeah it was
generated using those standard metric
factorization methods um and um
so we just assumed that they're present
in this work for now okay
thank you very much um